So the best way to find out about anything is to Google it. So I typed in Python
keyword from. Here I scanned all of the results
that were available, and then from there I landed
on this web page. By the way the link to this web site is also available in the
instructor notes. Now this webpage says that Python's from
statement let's you import specific attributes from a module. So
I guess it allows you to say from module or filename import something. So I
guess our code that means, that from
something called twilio.rest, we want to import TwilioRestClient.
Now, this got me curious about what
these things called Twilio.rest and TwilioRestClient were. So
then I went back to Google and tried
to find out how Twilio was actually implemented,
so I typed in Twilio Python Code. Then
I looked through these results and I got to
this website called GitHub. Here I could read
all of the code that actually makes Twilio work
behind the scenes, by the way, this link
is also available in the instructor notes. Now in
the code for twilio I find that there was
a folder called twilio so I clicked on it,
now inside that folder is another folder called rest. And within
rest there is a py on file which, if we look through, we will find that there is
a class called class TwilioRestClient inside it. So when we write this line
of code from twilio.rest import TwilioRestClient
what we are telling the computer is, hey, inside Twilio. There
is a folder called rest and inside that folder
is a class called twlio rest client and we are
going to use that class inside our code. And
if we go back and look in our code here
is how we are using that class twilio rest
client. Now you know if we were writing this code
from scratch we probably wouldn't have written this line
of code. We would have modified it to say from
twilio import rest. Now with this line of code, what we are telling the computer
is, hey inside the folder twilio is
another folder called Rest. Import that because we
are going to use that in our program, and we know that inside the folder
rest is the class TwilioRestClient. So I would
now access that class by saying rest. TwilioRestClient.
Let me save, and run this program one more
time to see if it still works. All right?
Here's my phone and let's see if I get
a text message any time soon. [SOUND] Ah-hah! There's
the text message, it seems like our program still
works. So in the next video what I want to
do is revisit the idea of how twilio, rest,
and twilio rest client are related with one another.